Hey, this is just amazing as I like to say,
you really can't write this stuff.
Donald Trump's attorney, or we think he's,
well maybe his attorney, Rudy Giuliani, but
dialed a reporter and was overheard talking
about how he needs cash and saying negative
things about Joe and Hunter Biden.
Now what?
But dial of course for those uninitiated is
when you have your mobile phone in your pocket
and it unlocks and accidentally call someone
and they pick up and they say hello, hello.
But they just hear whatever conversation is
taking place in the background or wherever
the color is.
But the best part is that this wasn't just
any butt dial on October 16th Rudy Giuliani,
but dialed a reporter for NBC news named rich
Shapiro.
Rudy had actually spoken to Shapiro earlier
the same nights, so it might've been like
a redial of the most recent name or number
in the call log at 11:07 PM Rudy's phone calls.
Shapiro's Shapiro was sleeping.
It goes to voicemail and a three minute long
voicemail is left.
Now, often three minutes is the maximum voicemail
length before it automatically stops recording.
That's at least the case with the David Pakman
show, voicemail number.
We have a lot of experience with people calling
and hitting that max and then being cut off.
Uh, Rudy was talking to someone else and he
was talking about needing cash.
You hear Rudy say, let's get back to business.
I got to a, I got to get you to get on Bahrain.
Giuliani says at one point, the problem is
we need some money.
There's then nine seconds of silence and then
Rudy Giuliani says we need a few hundred thousand
Rudy during this, but dial voicemail refers
to Robert several times.
That could be Robert Mangus.
Robert Mangus is a lawyer who happens to be
a registered agent on the behalf of the Turkish
government.
Rudy used to work for the same law firm until
about a year ago.
I'm also fascinatingly, this isn't even the
first time that Rudy Giuliani has, but dialed
the same reporter.
Last time it happened, he was trash talking
the Bidens.
It was months ago, and he had said, uh, in
the butt dial, things like Biden has been
trading in on his public office since he was
a Senator going on to say about Hunter Biden.
When he became vice president, the kid decided
to go around the world and say, hire me because
I'm Joe Biden son, and most people wouldn't
hire him because he had a drug problem also
saying his son altogether made somewhere between
five and 8 million.
A 3 million transaction was laundered, which
is illegal as we've referred to before.
This is stupid Watergate, stupid Watergate.
Their stupidity and incompetence are matched
or exceeded only by the Trump is too are gullible
enough to think that everything is fine and
everything is normal.
I was thinking, uh, you know, people like
to say, who would play Trump if a movie was
made about this administration, would it be
Alec Baldwin or would it be somebody else?
If you make a film about this administration,
how do you do it in a way that doesn't appear
to be a comedy, particularly for people decades
from now who may be, don't, hadn't lived through
what it is that we are living through today.
Why do I constantly have to double check to
see if I'm reading the onion or a satirical
news website when I read about what it is
that people associated with this administration
are doing?
How is Rudy Giuliani, anyone's lawyer, nevermind
lawyer to the president of the United States
of America and what so to to be serious for
a moment here, what we learn from this, but
dial what we learned from what this reporter
heard in the voicemail that was left is that
the Rudy Giuliani being involved with trying
to smear and go after the Biden stuff has
been going on for many, many months.
We've recently learned about this.
We recently found out about the July 25 Ukraine
phone call, which was just a few months ago.
This has been going on at minimum since the
beginning of 2019 or close to it, if not 2018
or even earlier.
And the, the only thing that I want to know
is the full extent of how deep Rudy Giuliani's
involvement goes because it is very clear
that he is up to his eyeballs in this stuff.
And we may never know because no matter what
subpoenas Rudy Giuliani gets, he may ignore
them.
If Democrats don't actually enforce those
subpoenas.
I hope we will someday learn the full truth
of it.
I'm not optimistic that we will.